[موسيقى]
يمكن اعتبار هذا المدفع هو اول مدفع الي
في التاريخ كان يتكون من ست سبطانات او
مواسير يتم تلقيمها بشكل اوتوماتيكيا
القوات الامريكيه الاتحاديه كانت اول من
استخدم هذا المدفع في الحرب الاهليه
الامريكيه ومنحها في هذا الوقت تفوقا
كبيرا على
[موسيقى]
اعاده الولايات المتحده احياء استخدام
المدفع خلال حرب فيتنام عبر تصنيع الميني
والذي اعتمد على الطاقه الكهربائيه
لتشغيله بدلا من العجله اليدويه تميز
حينها بسرعه اطلاق وصلت الى سته الاف طلقه
في الدقيقه الواحده
[موسيقى]
سنوات خضعت هذه المدافع لعمليات تطوير حتى
وصلت الى مدفع الفولكن وهو عيار 20
مليمترا واعتمدت عليه القوات الجويه
الامريكيه منذ عام 1959 كسلاح اساسي
لمقاتلاتها حتى يومنا هذا يعد مدفع عيار
30 ملم واحدا من اقوى مدافع الجاتلينج
والذي يستخدم على الطائرات الهجوميه
المضاده للمدرعات في الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]